- What's up Believe Nation it's Evan.
My one word is believe and I believe
that you have the ability to
do something really special,
and I want to play, a
small part in your success
with these videos that I'm making.
And so to help you on your
journey, today I'm continuing the
How Billionaires Think,
Success Advice From the
Top Series, Volume Three.
And as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy!
(dramatic boom)
(intense, inspiring melody)
- The thing about being
an entrepreneur is,
it's just, all to you.
You know a lot of people
like to make excuses,
I don't have connections,
I don't have money,
I don't have this, but, you know,
if you find something that
you like to do or love to do,
be great at it,
and see if you can turn
it into a business.
And worst case,
you're going to have fun doing
what it is you love to do.
And best case, you can
turn it into a business.
I'm just not big on excuses,
I just think if you're really,
everybody has that
opportunity to go for it
they just got to to do it.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- Turn your wounds into wisdom.
You will be wounded
many times in your life.
You'll make mistakes.
Some people will call them failures.
But I have learned that failure,
is really God's way of saying,
"Excuse me, you're moving
in the wrong direction."
It's just an experience.
(crowd applauds loudly)
Just an experience.
I remember being taken
off the air in Baltimore,
being told that, I was no
longer being fit for television,
and that I could not anchor the news
because I used to go out on the stories.
And my own truth was,
even though I'm not a weeper,
I would cry for the people in the stories.
Which really wasn't very
effective as a news reporter
to be covering a fire.
(audience laughs)
And crying because the
people lost their house.
And it wasn't until,
I was demoted as a on-air anchorwoman,
and thrown into the talk
show arena to get rid of me,
that I allowed my own
truth to come through.
And the first day I was on the air,
doing my first talk show back in 1978,
it felt like breathing.
Which is what your true
passion should feel like.
It should be so natural to you.
And so I took what had been a mistake,
what had been perceived as a failure
with my career as a anchorwoman
in the news business
and turned it into a talk show career
that's done okay for me.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- You are unusually fearless and willing
to go in the face of other people
telling you something is crazy.
And I know a lot of,
pretty crazy people, you still stand out.
Where does that come from
or how do you think about,
making a decision when everyone tells you
this is a crazy idea?
Or where do you get the
internal strength to do that?
- Well first of all I'd say I actually
think I feel fear quite strongly.
So it's not as though I just
have the absence of fear
I feel it quite strongly.
But there are just times when
something is important enough,
you believe in it enough,
that you do it in spite of fear.
- So speaking of important things--
- Like people shouldn't think I,
People shouldn't think well
I feel fear about this,
and therefore I shouldn't do it.
It's normal to feel fear.
Like you'd have to,
definitely something
mentally wrong with you
(laughs) that you shouldn't feel fear.
- So you just feel it and
let the importance of it,
drive you to do it anyway?
- Yeah, you know actually something
that can be helpful is Fatalism.
At some degree.
If you just accept the probabilities,
then, that diminishes fear.
So, when starting SpaceX
I thought the odds of
success were less than 10%,
and I just accepted
that actually, probably
I would just lose everything.
But that maybe we'd make some progress,
if we could just move the ball forward.
Even if we died, maybe,
some other company could
pick up the baton and move,
and keep moving it forward.
So we'd still do some good.
Yeah, same with Tesla, I thought the odds
of a car company succeeding
were extremely low.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- So many things go wrong,
when you're starting a company,
and often I think people ask,
"What mistakes should you avoid making?"
And my answer to that question is
don't even bother trying
to avoid mistakes,
because you're going to
to make tons of mistakes.
The important thing is
actually learning quickly
from whatever mistakes you
make and not giving up.
And, I mean there are
things every single year
of Facebook's existence
that could've killed us,
or made it so that,
it just seemed like moving forward
or making a lot of progress
just seemed intractable.
But you just kind of
bounce back and you learn.
Nothing is impossible
you just have to kind of
keep running through the walls.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- Does ideas matter?
Now people say of course ideas matter.
What kind of stupid life
lesson is it that ideas matter?
The truth of the matter is
this is both under and over-appreciated.
Most people think that
every idea is a good idea,
as long as they had it.
(audience laughs)
The truth of the matter is,
not every idea is a good idea,
not every idea matters,
and not every idea should be pursued.
And if you're in a field like I am,
or was, of innovation,
not every idea is a good idea.
Even if it strikes you
that way on first blush.
In fact most people are
lucky to have one idea
that really matters in their whole life.
That's not a criticism.
But earth-shattering, life-changing ideas
are very few and far between.
Research insights, investment
insights, innovations,
a good idea needs to be
cherished and nurtured.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- Most important thing is you have to--
there's two sides,
there's really sort of the
intellectual or mental side.
You have to pick a
business that has a niche.
You have to have a reason to succeed.
You have to be something
like we were doing, say
Japan can beat Germany in manufacturing
at this type of a product.
That was the niche really.
And then, on that,
you just have to have a
total and complete passion.
Because there's going to
be so many dark moments.
You know, I think that the dark moments
are true for any entrepreneur,
or any start-up company.
I'm sure that if you'd
talk to Steve Jobs at Apple
you'd see many, many, dark, dark moments.
Ours happened to last a little
longer than most of them,
but you really emotionally
have to be prepared
for those dark moments.
- I think, every entrepreneur
I've ever spoken to
would echo that.
- Yeah.
- That there are dark moments when
everything's on the line.
- That's the life of an entrepreneur.
And if you're going to be into it
you better be prepared for that.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- Going against the tide
is great if it works.
Now it doesn't always work.
And you really have to be
smart to go against the tide,
because you're going against
a lot of smart people.
But when you get it right,
you'll end up better.
Whether it's Microsoft or Google,
I mean so many people,
that have really hit big
have gone against the tide.
But you have to have great
confidence in yourself,
you have to be the right person.
There are very few people
that can pull it off,
but when you pull it off, it's great.
Same thing in real estate.
You go against the tide.
People are selling, you're
buying, the tide changes.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- The fundamental
connection to doing business
is basically relationships.
You know, people really, if
you really think about it,
people want to do business
with people they like.
I mean every now and then
you'll do a deal with the devil,
but you don't really like the devil,
but you do it sometimes.
(laughing)
But you really much rather do business
with somebody you like.
Somebody who shares your values,
somebody who you know
is committed to the
same objectives you are.
Somebody who's willing to
work as hard as you are.
And when you find those people,
those are the people you
want to bring under your tent
to be part of your business objective.
And, you've got to do that by,
you know sort of presenting
yourself in a way,
that people clearly understand
that you are committed to creating value.
Business people want to create value.
Doesn't mean that they
don't want to have fun,
doesn't mean that they don't want to be
involved in other kinds of things.
But if you can go to
someone and convince them,
that I can help you create value,
and by your ability to articulate that
and then to communicate it,
and to give people the impression
that you will work as hard as they will,
to create that value,
you're going to find people
wanting to come to you.
And so, for me it's sort of been like that
throughout my whole career.
Is being able to say to people,
talk to people in a way
that convinces them,
that I am going to do everything I can,
to help make what they
want to achieve a success.
And by extension I'm
going to be a success.
When I started BET,
the guy who invested in BET
is a guy named John Malone,
he was at that time the operator,
the third largest cable
company in Denver Colorado.
And he kept investing money into BET
without taking additional equity.
And as BET became a big success,
I ended up with about 75% of the company,
he ended up with about 25% of the company.
And one day I asked him
I said, "John, John,
"you put over a half a
million dollars in BET
"as a startup, you put it in as debt,
"you didn't put it in as equity."
Which would've given
him greater ownership.
I said, "Why'd you do it that way?"
And he said, "Bob I always knew,
"you would work harder for yourself
"than you would for me."
And it was that kind of commitment.
So if you could convey to people,
that you're willing to work hard for them,
and for yourself,
you got a business partner.
You're connecting the dots.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- You know there's a
very thin dividing line
between success and failure,
when you start a business from scratch.
If you don't have enough
money to pay the bills,
you've gone to the wrong
side of that dividing line.
And if you can somehow get
enough money to pay the bills,
you stay the right side
of that dividing line.
I've always been running
faster than perhaps I should,
and I've had great difficultly
saying no to things
so I keep on taking on new things.
And we've just managed
to stay the right side
of the dividing line over the
last 50 years in business.
But, equally in those early days
when you're starting a business
without any financial backing,
it's easy to slip the wrong side.
And in fact, most entrepreneurs
do slip the wrong side.
The important thing is then
just to pick yourself up
and start again.
And if it doesn't work at that time,
keep going until you do
succeed and not to give up.
(intense, inspiring melody)
- I want to talk about
dreams for a second.
And in my case,
literally a dream.
When I was in college,
I was sure that I'd been
admitted by a clerical error.
Probably a computer error.
(crowd laughing)
And because of that I
had an irrational fear,
I'd be sent home on the bus.
And (mumbles) knows this is true.
But it turns out,
because of that anxiety,
I woke up literally with a dream.
And it was kind of a strange dream.
It went like,
I think I could download the entire web,
onto some multiple computers
that were lying around.
And, that could probably seem
pretty crazy to most people.
But I stayed up a couple of
hours in the middle of the night
doing some math, and it seemed
actually pretty plausible.
While assuming you actually didn't keep
any of the web pages.
You only kept the links.
And then, sort of figured out,
given all that data I thought
it would take a couple weeks.
And, I told my advisor that.
And he just sort of laughed at me.
And of course it took a year or two.
But at the end of that,
we had a way to rank web pages,
and no thoughts to search at all.
But eventually, search
entered the picture.
And you know the rest.
And that became Google.
(audience clapping)
So I'd like to encourage everyone,
to follow their dreams.
- Thank you guys so much for watching!
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did you think,
what did you take from this video,
what was the most memorable
or most applicable lesson
that you're going to immediately implement
into your life or your business somehow.
Let me know down in the comments below.
I'm looking forward to hearing
what you guys have to say.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, see you soon.
(dramatic boom)